[Music]
you two are hungry
yep good thing you made a fresh plate of
i'm gonna say strained orange pulp
mashed potatoes with amber food coloring
a pile of sunny d slushy
i'm not sure what it is but don't you
try to pull off that vomitous mass's
eggs
you know better can i kill god summer
took out an onslaught of underwater foes
in the previous episode
how would she not be useful when going
to battle anyone
ensure she's a clone so maybe that
wasn't this summer but it's too early in
this episode to know that
sweetie don't get all worked up before
your job interview job interview
show doesn't resolve this i mean i know
that's the point but you can almost hear
the audible glee in the writers room
when they're like
let's introduce b-plot hanging threads
so we can troll the audience with this
ultimately meaningless episode
and you know how much i hate threads and
things that are hanging
so jerry morty are shot side by side but
in the overhead view they're now
separated by a table
and hey where did that juicy plate of
not eggs go oh no
they died this show has killed its main
character so much that caring about them
is like eating your eighth piece of
pizza i mean you still like pizza and
all but at that point you've eaten too
much but also once you get to eight is
nine really gonna make that much of a
difference
so you stuff it down like the
meaningless hunk of matter it is and
wonder if anything even means anything
anymore
hunt me hunt me somebody hug me
if sweaty death wish here truly wanted
to be hunted he'd be hiding in a bit
more stealth
what he should be saying is chase me
chase me or kill me kill me
i'm mr always wants to be hunted yes and
how interesting did you think that would
stay
joe then proceeds to hunt itself for the
next 20 some minutes making another
self-referential dig which in turn makes
my job even harder so
ding it i shall golf well i don't see
any stakes in them
summary of the biggest issue with rick
and morty at this point somehow makes it
into the episode
and by somehow i mean the writers
intentionally put it there as a meta
wink to self-defuse any criticism
because
they probably think it's not a bug it's
a feature but in either case it is a sin
so the new family we think is our family
suddenly dies and i guess this is the
part where i remember that it isn't a
new season of rick and morty until we
have a good old game of forsmith monty
the only explanation is to how this
green car missed the arrival of a
spacecraft and the obliteration of the
adjacent vehicle is distracted driving
put your phones away people holy crap is
morty call me by your naming at the age
of 14.
when the outside grows on the inside and
then reaches back outside your plant
addiction has gone too far
how many lavender shirts does one person
who only wears coral shirts need
this armor somehow flattens the
basketball hoop on the garage without it
moving folding or pieces of it flying
off
and also leaves large sections of the
roof and walls unprotected
rick would suck at purge survival is all
i'm saying decided it was maybe better
as a kind of kinetic mislead for another
special episode
geez ricky moore you sew up its own ass
with his fourth wall destruction and i
swear an episode in season six will just
be a static camera filming the actual
actor's table read
it will be so clever but then eat people
yeah during this scene i thought oh
interesting i'm eating popcorn too
and then as each murder devolves into
organs and viscous explosions my level
of popcorn enjoyment began to wane
this is a sin for me forgetting to never
eat while watching this show i'm not
looking at your ass
public beaches summer you [ __ ] idiot
calling your granddaughter an idiot
while concurrently exposing your in her
direction
jerry come on family emergency a bigger
emergency than my lemon square's not
setting
you mean those lemon squares that appear
to be stacked nicely on top of each
other
indicating that they have indeed set
pretty well all right we've seen enough
of these decoy houses to ask the
question are we really suggesting that
all these decoys have been set up with
not only identical houses but in
identical
neighborhoods and most importantly why
do they all have the driveway crack from
when the house was removed and replaced
in season one
i think you got the wrong house bro
analysis mode password eight zero zero
eight five kind of expected a funnier
password i kind of expected a rick would
have shot another rick in the head
already in the time it took him to make
that password boobs joke
are the golden circles the decoys or the
concentric circles
and why is there no text on the map so
we can point out inconsistencies this
map is confusing
and is hindering my ability to do my
intended job of actually pointing out
real sins instead of just making jokes
or hindering my ability to make jokes
instead of just pointing out real sins
depending on who you listen to analysis
mode eight zero zero eight five hmm
no but if these aren't this rick's
decoys then why were they on this rick's
terrible map
analysis mode password eight equals sign
equal sign capital d
honestly the vertical bar number three
works better in most fonts go ahead and
throw in a few more equal signs while
you're at it
am i right fellas before you say
anything they were already killing each
other and you saw that through
two walls also three spaceships a lava
gun a house engulfed in flames and
exactly
zero nosy neighbors show doesn't know
how to suburb correctly
connery plays the spaniard but does
nothing about his accent presumed decoy
rick would be excellent at cinemasins
on tv sins i say we split up some of us
take down squids while the rest
agent b stories will have to track
simultaneously no thank you
the indie conversations why are we
wearing these
better question where did you get these
they have an assortment of fabrics and
foam to construct these costumes
did they make a stop at the fabric store
there's one conveniently
why is jerry even holding an active bomb
after the crash is it in any way in
jerry's character to be aware of how to
do something like this or even want to
do it in the first place
it's either accidentally convenient or
out of character and cindy is hungry
today so
feast city feast how exactly are these
restraints containing the smiths they
have room to breathe they have room to
wriggle out the top of these things
can't kill you yet the skin needs to be
fresh
so why peel the skin off at all if the
skin is removed from its blood supply
it'd likely start to die pretty quickly
the peeled skin is already unfresh is
what i'm saying also you can't simply
banana someone and still leave the
victim alive
at least that's what jeremy told me come
on there's a place we can go
and despite knowing that all the clones
sorry decoys would also be somewhat
programmed to want to kill each other
they do in fact go
is this decoy missing his pickle rick
doesn't appear that mr skin cut it off
and you can't spell decoy without the d
what about the squids the summers are
going to explain that the squids were
decoys who realized they were decoys and
wanted to kill the other decoys and sure
sure fine whatever but in a world of
apparently countless decoys
have none of them died before now to
start this asimov cascade have you
met jerry like 12 percent of jerry's die
within the first year of existence
i mean is that something anyone wants
now the only way to prove i'm real and
not him
self-referential exposition the shield
lowers and somehow this version of the
family is battle chart and bruised which
seems unlikely because their shield has
been protecting them up until now
and also in the previous shot they were
completely normal i'll just point out
once again that
no one outside of the smith family seems
to be interested in this insane activity
happening all around them
not one civilian passing car straight
animals police officer or really
anyone is alarmed by what is happening
in these streets you want to get in one
more i told you so about synthetic life
or whatever this week's theme is how are
these mouths moving
big bird's mouth moved because one of
the puppeteer's arms was actually moving
his head instead of big bird's other arm
but clearly both arms are functioning
here as rick gestures around so what
moves the mouth
i want to say technology i want to
believe technology and i think it's just
convenient animation because
those heads are as hollow as a
presidential promise
rick survives this i think or decoy rick
maybe survives whatever this is someone
survives
something that much i'm sure ha both
jerry stop
fighting to hug hunty mcgiverson here
one shot fatality is the entire smith
family but only wounds rick for
reasons and did you just bleep oh yeah i
hear it now
you should have hunted me what since the
show apparently wants to sin itself
i'll let rick handle it from here were
you significant like like did we tee you
up
you want to be hunted god i have so many
questions
the decoys decoys decoys decoy decoy
decoys decoy decoy decoy decoy decoys
[Music]
decoys decoys decoys decoys decoys
decoys the decoys decoys
coil decoys decoys decoys decoys decoys
decoy decoys decor
decoy decoy decoy decoys
decoys decoys decoy decoy
[Music]
just the decoy stud decoy family you
made
more clones you're clones you're copies
of people
out here in the world what clones what
coffees what are you talking about
my spinach puffs saved them that's great
good job very good watch it they're
still hot
what the [ __ ] you think you're doing
down there you're making decoys you make
a copy of a copy it's not
quite as sharp as well the original we
can work this out just stop trying to
kill each other the mistake you made
was you killed my friend so i'm gonna
kill each and every one of you
and the only disappointment in it for me
is that i only get to do it once
you ever make a copy of a copy i like
pizza i like it
[Music]
nice bieber